pour le bon fonctionnement de leur
secteur les travaux publics ont besoin
d'une activité est linéaire une période
électorale ça peut bousculer les
plannings stopper des chantiers et créer
ce que la profession appelle un trou
d'air et cette période d'inertie peut
commencer bien avant les élections
notamment pour ménager la campagne des
candidats sortants et certains élus qui
veulent éviter de faire des nuisances
aux riverains dont qui réduisent le
nombre de chantiers pendant ces périodes
d'élection mais il ya aussi surtout
cette année là c'est une année où la
l'ancienne mandature n'a pas forcément
lancer des chantiers et la nouvelle
mandature attendent à faire un
inventaire pour pour démarrer de
nouveaux chantiers nouveaux projets pour
assurer une continuité dans les
investissements la fédération des
travaux publics s'adresse donc aux
maires et aux candidats pour les
rappeler à leurs responsabilités
chiffres à l'appui en côte-d'or l'eau
potable par exemple cours dans 3000 km
de conduite qui laisse cuire près de 20%
de leurs contenus les six mille six
cents kilomètres de voirie sont pour
moitié à la charge des communes quant à
l'éclairage public
il n'est plus tout jeune alors changé
par exemple un réseau existant le projet
n'est jamais très vendeur ça fait des
nuisances et au bout du compte
l'usager ne verra pas de différence mais
ça fait partie de ce patrimoine dont les
communes ont la charge des élus sont en
responsabilité d'un patrimoine qu'ils
vont léguer aux générations futures
donc effectivement quels que soient les
partis quels que soient les courants
on les invite à je dirais à être en
responsabilité vis-à-vis de cette notion
la plus les infrastructures sont de
qualité plus les entreprises puis les
services et plus les personnes sont
amenés à s'installer sur ces territoires
doit encore apporter une vraie dynamique
sociale et économique
quoi qu'il en soit période électorale ou
pas le secteur se porte plutôt bien en
ce moment dans la région les travaux
publics prévoit de recruter 2000
personnes dans les trois prochaines
années